also new at 11 the culinary academy of  las vegas  going to be hosting a large food basket  drive december 18th  and 19th to those impacted by covet each  basket will contain a roast beef  butternut squash  carrots celery potatoes rice pasta and  trimmings the drive will be held again  over two days the 18th and the 19th  15 000 baskets will be handed out  drive-through lanes will be set up at  sam boyd stadium  from 8 a.m to 4 p.m now you must reserve  your basket  by clicking on our story at eight  newsnow dot com or by calling  702-227-8842  additionally baskets will be distributed  to those who've been either  diagnosed or lost a family member to  covet  in laughlin mesquite as well as moapa